live streaming
is on okay it looks like
we are a lot so welcome everybody
to team com podcast number three we're
really
looking forward to this discussion and
we really appreciate everyone
who has come out to come speak with us
so without further ado i'm going to
share my screen and we're going to jump
into
our podcast section
so this is team com podcast
number three
welcome to team com everyone this is a
recorded and an archived live stream
that we're performing we are an
experiment
in online team communication and
learning and we are the active inference
stream for now
so people can connect with us via
twitter at inferenceactive
at this gmail address here we have a
public key based team
and also if you're watching this you
probably know but we're on youtube
at this username we really welcome
all skills backgrounds and perspectives
so please let us know how we can help
you and help help provide an on-ramp for
wherever you're coming from
and please be respectful of the rules of
online communication and dialogue
so you if you're not speaking if there's
noise in the background
you can use the raise your hand feature
which is on the bottom
left of jitsi and so on
and please provide us with feedback so
we can be improving
our work here's going to be the
structure of the discussion today first
we're going to have a
check-in and a warm-up then we're going
to briefly cover
tin bergens for questions which are a
big idea
that help us organize some of the
concepts that are discussed in the paper
then we will get to discussing the paper
we'll talk about the goals of the paper
and the abstract we'll go through the
road map of the paper and talk about the
section headers and how the authors get
from a to z
we'll talk about each one of the figures
and try to understand them
and then we'll have time for questions
throughout as well as at the end
so in the check-in or warm-up everyone
absolutely feel free to introduce
yourself
briefly and your location however you'd
like and maybe
for each of these questions if one or
two people could just
give a first thought so first warm-up
question is
what is communication
people can raise their hand or just kind
of pop corn in
yeah go ahead jared uh yeah so
alright yeah so hi everyone my name is
uh jared faisal i'm
uh uh in north carolina in uh
in the united states of america um
yes uh for me communication is just uh
a kind of a set of behaviors and
inferences that
people use to align their mental states
it's kind of like an abstract
i think kind of way to think about it
but um it inherits from my advisor's
line of thought that communication is a
sort of tool for people aligning their
mental states to a degree good enough
for their purposes
um yeah that's that's it i'd
like to think of it as a behavior that's
extended that uh
is like a sort of continuous extension
of
uh behaviors that species across the
animal kingdom use
um trying to think of it in a way that's
anything too too special
in linguistics for instance thought of
something very very special and unique
and it is in a certain way but
uh the way that i found it useful to
think about communication is as a
another sort of behavior in people's
toolkits
any other thoughts on that
yep stefan
yeah i would say that i agree with what
was just said there actually and uh
if you take like an active embodied
approach you could say that the um
it's an extension communication is an
extension of
the organism into the environment but
one which can happen
with interactions with other organisms
also extending into their environment
and their niche
cool and that kind of presages this
second question which is
what is special interesting or important
about
human communication and could be nothing
could be
everything um any thoughts on that one
yeah so i have a thought that it's maybe
not super special
anything about human communication um my
name is shannon
i'm at the university of california in
merced
but because of the pandemic i'm at home
in south dakota for
the foreseeable future um but yeah i
think
what is special about human
communication is that it's
the point of view that we're coming from
so when we're like studying
communication across the animal kingdom
it's always the point of comparison
either implicitly or
explicitly um but
you can look at like anything from
non-verbal communicative behaviors of
like our primate relatives or even of
our pets with
us um like outside of their species or
even
of like chemical signals and plants um
so maybe there's just a question of
how much of something that we want to
call agency or intentionality
is necessary to call communication
important in a specific
um like niche or
specific animal or plant kingdom or
something like that
very nice and science as a special form
of human communication it's the one that
we have
if nothing else and so as we kind of
continue to build towards the paper
how do prior beliefs so beliefs that
communicators
have about identity narrative or culture
play into communication in human or
non-human systems
sasha um yeah just
building on these really great previous
answers
i'm sasha i'm in davis california
um but i just wanted to say
that communication is highly
culture and context dependent and
in thinking about how to align
different peoples or organisms uh kind
of
views of the world culture
and context plays a big role in deciding
on how much to align
and whether or not that's important at
all
cool jared uh yeah so
um i wanted to
briefly say something about the second
point as well i for me real quick the
something that's maybe the the main
point of interest for me in terms of
human communication specifically human
communication is the
the uh goals of communicators in the
human
case tend to be or seem to be based on
um
a lot of for instance developmental and
cooperative research um
seem to be unique in that the goal is
the alignment of
mental states per se um so that turns on
gathering evidence for
that in terms of our interaction so i
have to get certain cues from you that
you understand what i'm saying and so
it's not you know
if you grab the thing for me that i i'm
asking you to get
by accident say accidentally you get the
thing that i wanted you to get
but you're also giving me cues that you
misunderstood what i said and so it was
just you know fortuitous
circumstance that you happen to get what
i wanted even in like young kids you'll
see them try to correct that and say
no you got the right thing this is
really what i wanted and so those sorts
of
that sort of result for instance um
suggests that
something that's unique is the
alignmental states per se
um rather than just having some
functional outcome
which is often the case in for instance
other non-human primates forms of
communication
um and then that turns into prior
beliefs for instance how does that
play an important role in communication
for me that's building what the
uh previous speakers said um
uh your prior beliefs
are the way or an important part of your
prior beliefs are the set of cultural
conventions that you learn
um i.e how a phrase or a
a mental state some how a a mental state
or intention should be
uh made manifest in the environment for
others to pick up on
that's a set of prior beliefs how do i
best do this something that your culture
installs in you through
all sorts of joint attentional practices
earlier in
uh earlier and earlier in in development
and that's also something that species
unique that other species
don't don't seem to engage in um is the
installation of these kinds of
culturally acquired
uh patterns and and
practices for communicating one's mental
states in a way that everyone deems
good enough for um sufficient for
current purposes i guess
cool yeah our last warm-up question
is for you what might a satisfying
formal framework for communication look
like and that might include
human and non-human it might include all
these features that people are talking
about but what would be the attributes
of a comprehensive or a formal framework
for
thinking about all this diversity of
communication styles in humans and
non-humans
what features would that kind of a model
be expected or desired to have
yes stiffen i think one of the key
things
is it would have a spatial component in
terms of how the dynamics happened
in space and around space particularly
personal space around
the organism and one of the key things
about humans is that we can also enfold
narrative within itself in story we can
and we spatially arrange things so we
often say
like that's right what's left what's
ahead what's been
so that ability to somehow
tag or embed within the niche
is key and then the actual language part
is somehow
tied to that rather than the other way
around which is what a lot of the kind
of
mind-based approaches it tends to be
cool shannon i think i'm touching up on
that
so having this account of how we use
space
in conversation it also needs to be
flexible enough to account what sasha
was talking about
the way different cultures use space
like putting the past in front of you
which is
awkward to me but makes a lot of sense
to other
other cultures um and also aspects of
communication that aren't linguistic
so non-verbal would be obvious but
communication and
like a musical situation um where no
not necessarily any semantic referent is
being
called upon but all the same we know
that we're
feeling the same beat or like we're
really
in the same abstract
space of interacting with each other
cool um yvonne or alex anything to add
on any of these
points
not by no cool i agree about
that um aspect where linguistics
are one of the modes of communication
and yet there's this spatial element
and sometimes they blur when you say do
you grasp it or can you see what i'm
talking about it's
very cross-sensory and you can type out
what you mean to say
yet we're sometimes talking about
specific things sometimes not
so let's just talk really briefly about
tin bergen's four questions which are
modeled off of aristotle's four wise
and this is a image from cap heim's
paper
from the u social insect literature and
tim bergen's four questions are kind of
like a two by two matrix
the two aspects on the left side the y
axis are whether the domain of analysis
is contemporary happening right now or
historical in the past
and then proximate or ultimate are
referring
not to ultimate like the best but rather
like close and far
again kind of a spatial metaphor and the
four
domains though they sometimes go by
slightly different names
are causation which is happening
approximately and now
uh utility which is happening it's the
ultimate y it's the it's the teleos
and it's happening now as well and then
in the proximate
version of history so recent history we
have development or ontogeny
and then the ultimate why of history why
do
birds have wings why are we here that's
captured by evolution and just to put a
little bit more of a specific
vision on this as we turn towards some
of the figures in the paper which will
involve birds
this is from bateson and lalon 2013
which was a 50-year update on tim
bergen's original 63 paper
and here's the same four categories of
mechanism which is causation
uh current utility development and
evolution reflected by
uh respectively the neuroscience the
actual
meaning of the song the developmental
basis of the song
which is showing the songs trace change
through time
and then the evolutionary history of the
trait reflected on a phylogeny
so any points on that or can we jump
into the paper
cool this was just to kind of bring up
this idea for those who are maybe coming
from outside of a philosophy of biology
background because it's a really awesome
framework and it helps us get on board
with this idea that there's going to be
more than one answer to why
not just because of just uh different
opinions
there's actually different kinds of whys
when we're talking about why is a bird
singing there might be multiple answers
just fundamentally
so the paper that we are here to talk
about today
and lucky enough to have jared the first
author here for a little bit longer
is a world unto itself human
communication as
active inference and what i sketched the
two goals of the paper down as
were to formalize cooperative
communication as a process of active
inference
under the free energy principle and to
link
the mechanistic developmental and
evolutionary perspectives on
communication
by using active inference as a process
theory
jared what would you say about that or
how does that reflect on what you've
intended when you wrote the paper yeah
no no i think that's
i think that's great and um i want to
put particular emphasis
within the context of the cs pacific
paper on the second point um
i really was hoping to um
yeah hone in on the idea that all these
different scales of analysis
are in some sense linked to one another
um i.e like you had mentioned in the
last slide you know if you want to
explain any kind of behavior or
inferential pattern or whatever that you
see any aspect of a phenotype in in
the animal kingdom that's gonna turn in
every single case
on to fully explain it on on explaining
what's going on in each of these
different scales of analysis and showing
how they all kind of fit into a coherent
poll in this case if you take the active
inference framework the kind of
the idea of gathering evidence for your
model your evolutionarily
uh favored model um that bottoms out in
in
real time uh sorts of behavioral
patterns um
that yeah i was basically trying to link
these different scales
um and show how they're all sort of part
of this evidence gathering procedure
um it emerges in this idea of
cooperative communication which is
something
from my advisor mike tomasulo and i hope
that uh that this will lead to some sort
of uh
future more uh technical explicit uh
formal analysis cool
and when i see tim burgin's four
questions i think about
yes and because not only is that a tenet
of
improv and communication as we know it
at the mechanism time scale
to foreshadow but it's like yes there's
evolution that's an explanation
and there's other kinds of explanations
that we want to be addressing as well so
it's kind of communication
through and through and integration
through and through
any other comments on the goals the
paper before we
get to the abstract
okay so let's work through the abstract
and see how the authors reflected or
summarized
for everyone what they did they wrote
the purpose of this paper is to extend
the account of human cooperative
communication
by proposing an integrative model of
biobehavioral dynamics of cooperative
communication
our formulation is based upon active
inference
active inference suggests that action
perception cycles
operate to minimize uncertainty and
optimize an individual's internal model
of the world
we propose that humans are characterized
by an evolved adaptive prior belief
that their mental states are aligned
with or similar to those of con
specifics
for example that we are the same sort of
creature inhabiting the same
sort of niche any thoughts or
comments on these first parts of the
abstract
so we're within this integrative
framework we want to bring together tin
bergen
as well as active inference with
hopefully an eye towards
more formal integrations that are
possible in the future
the use of cooperative communication
emerges as the principal means to gather
evidence for this belief again that
we're in a shared niche and that we're
similar kinds of interactors or english
speakers or we're interested in this
topic
allowing for the development of a shared
narrative that is used to disambiguate
interactants hidden and inferred mental
states
any thoughts on that part what does it
mean to disambiguate
the hidden and inferred mental states
well one thought on that shannon go
ahead oh
yeah um so i guess it's
not just to know what the other person
might be thinking
um or could say in words but also to
know that
you're both maybe attending to the same
reference or that you're both
experiencing a similar emotion
or if it's different like why is the
other person
sad right now um so any sort of
experience i suppose that two people
could be feeling it's to
figure out what they're feeling and what
you are feeling and
yeah a lot of them yeah
and we have such a rich internal
experience that it's not
enough just to infer the external states
of a person oh they're sitting down
uh big surprise we need to actually do a
lot of work
to disambiguate or to reduce our
uncertainty about hidden states which
are mental in this case
thus by using cooperative communication
individuals effectively attuned to a
hermeneutic niche
composed in part of others mental states
and reciprocally
attuned the niche to their own ends via
epistemic niche construction
uh jared what is a hermeneutic niche
and an epistemic niche how are those
similar ideas or different
yeah so the idea of a hermeneutic niche
is that you know
when we're when we're communicating we
both have our sort of individual
perspective so it's you know
um it's a an i or a me
and a you in addition to that there's
you know the we
the it's our shared dialogue um
we are talking about something um at the
same time of course we can decompose
that into like i just said our own
individual perspectives and so
what i was trying to get out there um
was
the idea of hermeneutics is if you all
have read for instance the first and
fifth 2015 duet for one paper um they
talk about this hermeneutic idea where
it comes from the idea of like a deep
reading of a text so
if you want to really fully understand
a text for instance you have to both
take words
in their immediate context in a sentence
in which they're composed then also
relate them to the larger context of the
paragraph or the the
um the chapter or the whole book or
whatever
um so the idea is relating these two or
more different scales of analysis to one
another
um and seeing it as a sort of
integrative explanatory whole
um and the epistemic niche construction
component uh
trying to link up with uh some of the
stuff that axel constant
um has been doing on niche construction
so um
we construct our niche so as to offer up
very precise
uh certain affordances for us
i.e we make our niche more easily
understandable
that could in this case in the instance
of
communication across long
stretches of intergenerational time you
see these patterns of
what using this this terminology
epistemic niche construction where
um languages cultures build up i should
say cultures build up a set of
constructions a set of four meaning
pairings um
[Music]
that if you align to that set of four
meaning pairings and
ontogeny makes your niche very easily
understandable
i.e easily inferable you can
easily grab a hold of others hidden
states as there were others mental
states
by using these sorts of uh uh very
reliable
um sort of epidemic tools or devices
which are
we talked about in the paper uh
communicative constructions
and and the way that you describe that
it makes me think about the
royal we in english and if somebody said
well
what am i talking about it's almost like
wait what are you talking about if
you're not sure what you're talking
about what are you talking about
but when somebody says what are we
talking about here it's a rhetorical
question that helps us
have a shared informational niche and i
agree axel's work in that respect is
excellent
this means that niche construction
enables features of the niche
to encode precise reliable cues about
the deontic
or shared value of certain action
policies e.g
the utility of using communicative
constructions to disambiguate mental
states
given expectations about shared prior
beliefs
what is deontic value in this context
jared or anyone else
maybe jared first and anyone else can
raise their hand
i think if if stefan wants to go oh
have in a in your environment so um
it can be useful so it's kind of a
longer standing queue that's kind of
established in the niche
um just one thing i was thinking when i
was seeing this i think it's quite
important that they're talking about
cooperative communication here
um and that narrows it down then to
something a bit more instrumental
um it's not necessarily coordinated
communication so it's not necessarily as
action-oriented as that but there is a
sense that this is trying to get to
we're trying to achieve or trying to
cooperate towards something therefore i
want to align my mental states
because if you're not cooperating with
someone you could be just trying to work
out the hidden states of like what is it
that it's important for me to talk to
them about which may not be their mental
state it just may be
their state in the world at the moment
if that makes sense which i think
this is like you've already got some
alignment and
assumed i think
right and if it's not cooperative it
might be adversarial which kind of takes
us to dennett's intentional stance
where you just say whatever it is if
it's a computer or if it's a human i'm
just trying to win this
little local game theory interaction and
the paper doesn't go
that direction it moves towards
cooperative communication so
jared any thoughts there yeah yeah so
this is
all great discussion and this um
building on the point you just said
about you know cooperative versus
adversarial sorts of
for instance communication um
even in the case of you know i say you
know i'm using communication
or shared language to try to outsmart
you or outdo you or something
um exercising like a kind of like
machiavellian
intelligence i think it's been called um
that still relies on you know the shared
presupposition i guess you want to use
that language of um
a cooperative bedrock so you know the
idea is if i'm using
this piece of language typically it's
for you know honest
genuine communicative goals and the idea
for instance deception relies on
me using you know kind of exploiting
that shared assumption
to my own benefit to your detriment um
so even at least in the case of humans
when you're you know lying or something
um adversarial communication or whatever
still relies on there being some shared
set of cooperative presumptions and that
that that is what is exploited um for
humans when they're communicating
um and also about the
the deontic value that those sorts of
ideas uh deontic or shared value that
um the idea there is that
we you know when in ontogeny when you
are
attuning to learning your culture set of
communicative constructions
what what these constructions are are
in speaker's brains there's um lots of
good work for instance from
someone who i like joan bybee that
suggests that these are very automatized
automatic
sorts of mappings between form and
meaning that
at least in their normal use don't
require
expensive heavy sorts of computations
maybe when you're first learning them
they do but
the more you use them and exercise them
in actual
joint practice with others uh in
aligning mental states
they become very automatic and so the
idea of geontic value is that it
bypasses
uh the deontic value of policy bypasses
all the kinds of heavy computational
updates that
might be required by for instance
someone learning how to use
constructions but
yeah and instead provides a very
automatic mapping between
states so it depends how you chunk a
construction but
constructions become linked up in a very
automatized way and then it can be used
effortlessly by speakers um that's the
idea of at least in this case the
deontical shared value of certain action
policies
ie constructions cool and and using the
niche
info niche uh idea it's kind of like a
tragedy of the commons
if people pollute the environmental
niche
it doesn't work as well as it could and
if people pollute the informational
niche
with deceptive signaling it also doesn't
work so it's a the niche metaphor
really works well so let's think about
the last part of the abstract
in turn the alignment of mental states
which are prior beliefs
enables the emergence of a novel
contextualizing scale of cultural
dynamics that encompasses the actions
and mental states of the ensemble of
interactants and their shared
environments
the dynamics of this contextualizing
layer of cultural organizational
feedback
across gales acts to constrain the
variability of prior expectations of the
individuals who constitute it and then
just to close it with the contribution
our theory additionally builds upon the
active inference literature by
introducing a new set of
neurobiologically plausible
computational hypotheses
for cooperative communication we
conclude with directions for future
research
any last thoughts on the abstract or can
we go to the roadmap
cool really awesome and it just shows
how much there is to unpack
in the very distilled representation of
the abstract
so and jared i know that you have to
head out at some point so feel free to
just anyone can bounce when they need to
yeah i was gonna say i'm gonna i'm gonna
head out right now actually i have to go
but thanks this was this was wonderful
thank you for uh
putting us on thank you we would love to
have you at a future conversation too
so see you later thanks cool
so the road map of the paper now now
that he's gone and we can really talk
about the paper
uh it starts with an introduction part
two
is a theoretical background and they
cover several of the key
areas of background which are the
evolutionary origins
and the developmental origins of
cooperative communication so two
different time scales evo and devo
often called then they take
stock and table one summarizes some of
the key features
that are related to cooperative
communication so two
a b and c don't have to do with free
energy they don't have to do it with
active inference
this is more classical understandings of
cooperative communication section three
is
explicitly about active inference first
they talk about the idea of active
inference broadly
and about how adaptive priors help
organisms relate in the world and about
the idea of alignment of
priors within the active inference
framework figure 1
and figure 2 show active inference in
the world
as well as active inference and
communication in the world and we're
going to look through each one of the
figures one by one
they then turn to the topic of deontic
values which are shared expectations
about the value of policies
so section three takes us from what is
active inference
and why is it important for
communication to what is this concept
of deontic value in the context of the
active inference framework
then they bring it together in section
four where they
uh more clearly talk about human
communication as active inference
first they look at the dynamics of
communication at the time scale of
mechanism
which is the individual in context as
well as the dyad which is the minimum
communicative unit then the dynamics of
communication at the time
scale of ontogeny or development and
then
zooming back one more level what are the
dynamics of communication
at the time scale of cultural evolution
figure 3 is a really nice representation
of the
communication and coupled action
perception cycle
figure 4 has some examples in the bird
song
as well as figure five of free energy
minimization
in the case of improvisational duets and
then
figure five is a duet for one learning
to synchronize through active inference
they then conclude with future
directions and conclusions
so we're going to get from introductions
to communication from an evo devo
perspective
through the free energy principle
inspired
framework of active inference to the
point where we're actually making
useful claims about the world within
what we've put together in sections two
three four and then leading to future
directions what might be interesting for
people to study
any thoughts on the roadmap or can we go
to the table
and figures cool
so table one would anyone else like to
give this a first summary
i put up on the top right the remember
the cap time
figure just so that we remember that
these are not uh they're not conflicting
uh layers of analysis or scales of
analysis they're they're all part of one
integrated
punnett square if you will and what
table one does is and anyone can just
raise their hand if they
want to jump in but otherwise i'll just
kind of keep the
error alive table one summarizes some of
these key features
that have to do with cooperative
communication using the terminology
in many cases from the non-active
inference community so that's why this
paper is such a bridge
from a conceptual and even a keyword
perspective
and these four scales of analysis which
are reflected by
tin bergen's four whys are the real-time
mechanism
and the characteristic dynamics there
have to do with ostension
which means to show or clearly
demarcated
joint attention which is people looking
at the same thing
and in the human case often the the um
whites of the eyes surrounding the
colors part of the eye have been
discussed maybe shannon if you're
familiar with uh with the non-human
primate literature
i know that the non-human primate and
humans have quite different eyes
and people have speculated that has to
do with attention
um also at the real time level there's
the
optimization of relevance which is if
someone says okay
i i know this part of trigonometry you
can skip through that it's not relevant
to me
or that word wasn't relevant to me
because i don't know what it is
so could you could you optimize the
relevance of your sentence
by defining the word coupled
bidirectional information flow
as well as approximate motivation to
align and coordinate mental states
uh like if somebody needs something and
you want to make sure you have the other
person's attention
hey i'm driving and i'm thirsty can you
get me this water bottle
if the other person's not paying
attention then you're gonna stay thirsty
but if the other person is paying
attention it's the motivation that you
have to align your mental states
so they can get you the water bottle um
and there's other
characteristic dynamics at the time
scale of development
phylogeny as well as adaptation any
any remarks on this
um yeah i was gonna say it makes a lot
more sense
that this is jared's advisor
to understand better the ontogeny of
communication or cooperative
communication
so i found this an interesting um
and really relevant bridge to
understanding
the onset of cooperative communication
in a person's life as well as comparing
it across species
but yeah i just thought that was a
very interesting and irrelevant
uh connection to think about how we
learn to
uh cooperate and make our uh
internal states known and that we
actually
are unsatisfied until we are able to
make our internal states known
cool stefan
yeah i kind of think i always find these
these
these the way they link with each other
kind of interesting um
and kind of um
could be read different ways um because
you could you could the real-time
mechanism could stretch out over
time in terms of how you think your
cooperation is going to have impact on
your life um as an as an elder
or as a teenager but
in some ways i kind of wonder if
everything in most organisms comes back
down to those evolutionary priors
and we're able to kind of play with
um well even even a puppy is different
to a full grown dog in terms of how they
fit themselves into establishing their
role in communication but we really do
go outside of what our gut feeling tells
us
and start to sort of change the rules of
the game so to speak um
about causation and ontology and current
utility
so it's it's quite it's quite useful in
terms of sort of generative
discussion beyond like what this
immediately says in a direct short-term
interaction
cool alex or yvonne any thoughts on that
and and also just if you you can raise
your hand if so um
one other thought is the two by two kind
of punnett square
layout makes us think if we threw a dart
it would be okay it's that's causation
that's utility that's development that's
evolution another
spatial metaphor would be like a wave
and a ripple on a wave
so the big wave is evolution um and then
there's smaller waves within that
and so yes it totally builds on the
evolutionary priors like you were just
saying
and it's totally about development
because that never stops either
and it's totally about the mechanism
because without mechanism you don't have
the
voice box or you don't have the audio
processing so it's all of those and
they're all happening in an
overlapping way that's not quite
reflected by the cleanliness of this two
by two or even a continuum
model cool any last thoughts on the
table or
can we get to the figures awesome
so here we are in figure one and for for
team com
this was a uh really a great image that
we had shared a lot before this
discussion
because it brings together the skeleton
of active inference in a way which is
this cycle that goes from internal
states which influence
through policy states action states
action states influence external states
of the world which are also influencing
each other
but we're not too worried about those
external states influence our
sensory states the retina and the
tympanic membrane and then the sensory
states
allow us to update our internal model of
the world that's also
generative so that's the very basic
skeleton
of the active inference cycle here
reflected with just
one agent in feedback with the world
and so the the flow is always going this
way
but also it's happened all these things
are happening all at once
your legs are always engaged in an
action state
your retina is always involved in a
sensory state even if your eyes are
closed
your internal states are always updating
so they're all happening at once
but we can kind of trace this causal
diagram
uh through time and then we also see
represented in this image the equations
and there is a level of
math that is just sort of brought up in
this paper and
cited to other places for where people
can learn more
but suffice to say that each of
these different uh sectors can be
thought of
as happening at various levels of
mathematical
description so in this center part of
the image
it shows like the the the minimal
version of the
uh math and then this is a little bit
more
fleshed out of an equation and then
there are citations
and future work to be done that really
builds it out
more fully so what does anyone else see
in figure one
i suppose not quite in figure one but in
something you mentioned
about the parts of your body that are
doing the action they're doing the
sensation
um is a great skeleton like you said
um but then there's all of the action
that's happening
constantly at sometimes consciousness at
the subconscious level
but likes the cods of the eyes so you're
constantly
having the small action to resample the
environment or
the like proprioceptive sensations of
your legs
so even within that larger
cycle there's all of these much much
smaller cycles happening where
this perception action loop is
functioning
in like every part of the sensorium of
your body
very nice good point and this image has
the sensations coming into the person
and this kind of puts the black box or
the markov blanket if you will
around the whole person but it's
actually
a nested markov blanket situation so
each neuron has internal states
action states external states for the
neuron which are other neurons
other cell types and then sensations so
this is something that
is about the world and about people but
it also
exists as a skeleton whenever we want to
draw the boundary around
any kind of uh active inference system
and thinking about communication more
broadly than the human case is where we
start to see oh yeah that's right
um honest communication is the norm
neurons don't expect each other
to be deceptive sure it might happen but
that's the decimal point
and the real framework is about how
cooperative communication goes down
because adversarial relationships just
don't persist over as long
of time durations or spatial durations
because they break down
almost by definition and so thinking
about this multi-level
in space as well as multi-time scale
kind of tying it back to the tim bergens
levels um or four questions and
there's a lot to this and it's awesome
and one of the key contributions
of the free energy principle which have
to do
with all of these equations that
potentially despite the differences in
the specifics
between time scales and spatial scales
and different modes of communication
there may be some similar equations
underlying the dynamics
and that would be something quite
fantastic
so let's build on figure one to figure
two
so here we go we have the same the same
colors
and the same layout here if you just
block
off one side of the picture and you just
look at this side for example
it would be the same thing the one
person with a sensory
uh the action states that influence the
world i guess
action and sense have been flipped here
it's the action states that influence
the world
and then comes back through sense to the
person
but the two key differences here first
off is instead of just
internal states um it's now reflecting
specifically the regime of
attention so that's salience or
attention and
it's thought it could be thought of as a
subset of the total
internal generative model of the world
by the brain but now we're talking about
what specifically the in the internal
model should attention be paid to
and then the key here and this is almost
the genesis of team com
in some senses is the world for
communicating agents is other
communicating agents
and it's a deceptively simple conclusion
or
claim because it's one thing when you
have the person in feedback with the
world
that makes it it's kind of i'm thinking
about tom hanks playing ping pong
against a wall
it's him he's he's in feedback it's a
it's a dynamical system
but the fixedness of his opponent
makes the uh moves that he makes very
very
uh specified and easy to determine
whereas once you even get two that are
communicating and they have different
attention they're paying attention
different things because they have
different internal
models all of a sudden you get these
totally novel and
improvisational dynamics that they call
thinking through other minds
any thoughts on this
that was a really great tom hanks ping
pong metaphor though for
i mean it'd be it would be that easy if
you were just typing to a chat box and
then it just
copied and pasted exactly what you wrote
back for example it wouldn't be quite a
conversation
and then you could imagine speaking to a
chatbot or something like that and
maybe attention is playing out
differently on the computer
versus in your brain so the internal
states are different but again we kind
of already knew that the action states
are different
the point is the shared epistemic
resources so the epistemic
being related to the knowledge the cues
for the chat box what time the message
was sent or
who the person who sent it was the cues
and the resources
are a shared resource they're a shared
niche and then
each of those uh agents depending on
which sense
states make it to their regime of
attention
are going to update their action
policies in a different way
and so one other thing i really like
about this framework for communication
is it highlights the the necessity and
the importance of alignment
but not perfect alignment it actually as
a starting place
takes that different people are going to
be coming from different perspectives
it's not that there's one correct
interpretation of what person a says
and if person b gets it perfectly they
succeed and if they don't get it
perfectly they failed
it's kind of an absolutist notion of
communication
and here we take a really fully
pluralist approach to communication
where
you have two communicating agents they
have different internal models of the
world
and the communication is happening in
this world that they share
in the informational and in the physical
niche that they share
and it's actually an action-oriented
interaction that the agents are engaged
in that's happening as their very
different internal models are aligning
and so it highlights the process of
alignment without
being too hard on the need for a perfect
alignment and
that just in so many situations is a
helpful
starting point about where where am i at
in this conversation
where is my conversant in this
conversation how are we going to align
what is this alignment for any
thoughts here uh
let me try to end about maybe
about actions because as for this model
and everything is about alignment
of the models and actions are like not
side effects
but not a primary one for example if a
team or a company speaking about playing
actions some kind of strategies
or something like this
basically it's again about alignments
and that's why
if a company or team want
to develop something or make some
research
it's need to planning recursively
not from actions but from
models and alignments
yeah and to kind of give an example that
if we were uh
working together on a team to build a
car the goal isn't to
align on what the perfect car would be
the goal
is the action of actually making that
car happen
and that's going to require us to
synchronize on mental states but also
contribute
our unique skills and perspectives and
then to give
one more example about action um
declarative speech is an action it's an
action it's a motor behavior it has to
do with the way that muscles move so
speech
is an action this is one action that
results in speed in
sound clapping but their body actions
that result in different cues and so
placing
speech uh fundamentally as an action
state it helps us get away from this um
well you have
acts and then you have speech but of
course there are speech
acts and speech is an action and in
pure conversation where the feedback is
happening through conversation
uh it gives us that same uh
action-oriented uh model that we can
apply
to non-linguistic systems and now we're
thinking about speech
as an action in a communicating system
so we can really
build on the strengths of linguistics
like jared was talking about
without overly making it about the
specifics of any human
communication style or even a cultural
communication style because
speech is again just one of the many
multi-faceted ways
that we share information and that we
call people's attention to different
features of the world
any thoughts on figure 2 or anything
else any questions yeah stefan
i think this is all this is also good
for bringing
um action into what language is about
like action is out there in amongst the
world as part of sort of interacting
with
rather than being these representations
in the minds that codify everything
so i think it's quite um it's quite
useful to see that and see the world in
the background
um so yeah one thing i find in some ways
i'll always be interested to see if
there was a triad here to see how that
would play out
because because that might really bring
that out
um but it is interesting that the
descriptions you were given there around
how things are unfolding and i i didn't
haven't quite unpacked all the equations
but i think there's something
useful in like there's something about
the epistemic resources and more like
general complex adaptive systems which
maybe aren't entirely stable
but kind of they're interacting and
bounces off each other
and the more internal stuff is much more
noisy non-linear and
it's a sort of achievement between like
entities in the environment
bouncing with each other and our kind of
non-linear kind of free energy trying to
understand what's that all about by
minimizing free energy so i think
this is actually quite there's quite a
lot that can be played around
awesome um yeah i agree about the the
getting more than two actors so we can
imagine another
yellow box up here and through action
states it's contributing to the
epistemic resource and we can be
super specific let's think about this
video chat
so the action states are what people are
speaking about
and the sensory states are happening to
me through my eyes
as i look at the screen and through my
ears as i'm listening and
through the sensations that i'm
receiving i'm updating the regime of
attention
when i see a little uh cue an ostentive
cue like a little
blue box around the speaker that's
putting my attention
to not just where i should be looking
but
conceptually what i should be paying
attention to
um and then it also relates to the
hermeneutics idea that jared was
bringing up
and so i'm imagining this epistemic
resource our shared informational niche
is we're all seeing basically the same
six boxes
on our screen our shared informational
resources
are identical and we can in a computer
system even know that they're identical
but each one of us are going to unpack
in a different way
what is being said and so it's like the
book's on the table
and someone says the meaning is in the
book well it's not
technically in the book it's not
physically contained in the book that's
a spatial metaphor that it's
in the book and so where is the meaning
well if the meaning
is in the relationship between the
regime of attention
and the shared epistemic resources well
then you get
almost pluralism for free you get this
idea that different people
are going to by looking into the book in
their own unique way they're going to
unpack the book differently
maybe one person doesn't read the
language and so the book doesn't reduce
their uncertainty about anything
but for someone else who's very familiar
with the work of the
author potentially they can read between
the lines
and even see things or unpack things in
the book that aren't
directly there and so we get all these
amazing
special cases and and uh richness of
communication
coming out within this scaffold and so
again just to go from figure one
where okay this is just the minimal
possible
active inference cycle just external
states internal states
and then the markov blanket is being
pierced on the inbound
by sense and being pierced on the
outbound by action
let's just zoom one layer out now we're
looking at the dyad
and also we can just say the dyad's not
just their
um dissipating energy for nothing
they're communicating to a line on
something
we're here to reduce our uncertainty
about this paper and about the free
energy principle about
active inference um as well as other
goals
and so all of this is already starting
to come out just
as we qualitatively look at it and i
agree that the mathematics
uh of complex adaptive systems and
free energy principle provide a lot of
those non-linear dynamics that we
would want to see for a formal
communicative framework
i think it's a good time to show figure
three this is
the last figure in this sequence of
three
so here we're kind of just um specifying
uh again just drawing out again this
communication between two brains
and it's one canonical loop of the
coupled action perception cycle
so we're keeping in mind it's always
happening continuously
and we're just going to trace out one
loop it's kind of like we
inject a little dye into the river we're
just going to look at the trace as it
goes just through one small part to get
a bigger
sense about the flow so it starts with
my idea and my idea is going to
influence
my behavior that my behavior is going to
fill out or pour into that epistemic
niche my behavior in this case
is a vocal behavior and then through our
shared informational niche
my behavior is going to result i mean
this arrow
you can imagine putting in other steps
intermediating here like
going through the ear and going through
this cortex and that cortex
but just broadly my behavior will result
in
your version of my idea i said grab a
gallon of milk
and use you got it okay i got it a
your version of my idea is going to
uh result in combination this is the x
your ideas and your version of my idea
come together
and that is going to influence your
behavior then
we're back right where we started where
your behavior is going to say
ah okay right they said exactly the
thing that i wanted from the grocery
store back to me so their behavior
suggested that the attentional regime
was there
that the semantic content of what i
wanted to convey was their
i'm pretty convinced that my
understanding
of what you thought i said was accurate
aka the alignment was adequate
doesn't need to be perfect but for the
purposes of that communication
the alignment was adequate and then my
ideas
and how i perceived your perception of
them combined
again in the generative model the brain
and that's going to influence behavior i
say okay great glad you got it here's
five bucks
go ahead and do this so this is just
tracing one loop
but already we get so many of these cool
patterns and ways to think about how
different sources of
prior information like my idea your idea
relate to the uh just in time
information that we receive everyone has
years and years and years of their own
thinking
and then someone says hey what do you
think about this policy
and they're combining this recent
sensory information from the person
asking the question
with a really big and rich sensory
regenerative model of the world and so
we we can capture that short term
information as well as these deeper
developmental and evolutionary aspects
of
of thought together in this type of a
model
and again it's just a wireframe but what
does this
um lead anyone to think about or what
what might be
uh uncertainty that some of our
listeners would have about this
figure one two three sequence
yeah shannon i suppose in this figure
one two three sequence
um everything seems like this event
right now
um and what's left out is this iterative
process
um so like going through the
these chains of language learners
and as you get to the end you might get
a simple
construction by the time you get to the
end
or chains of interactions between people
where my idea is continuously being just
slightly adjusted by your version of my
idea which slightly adjusts
each other node in this figure until
we as a dyad um sort of start to align
on the like sort of
final state or something of our
interaction um
which is brought up a lot in the paper
but it's not
it's not super clear just from seeing
these these three figures sort of in a
sequence
yep anyone else there maybe
sasha how do you think this relates to
improvisation
or where improvisation takes interactors
um yeah i i quite like this figure
um adding the extra or
kind of the next logical step that um
it's about
not just how i'm expressing my idea but
what is your version
of the idea that i'm expressing um
and yeah i think it's
um yeah very relevant for
uh improvisation and i'm just thinking
of like context
uh specific clues that we get from
iterative interactions and um
i'm thinking like almost like a secret
language you know that
you'd be able to speak in code
once you did it once to the person you
would know what these words mean
kind of going forward but um
as shannon mentioned like that wouldn't
be captured in in this
um in this figure uh precisely
um or explicitly um
but to know that uh when you're in this
location
you call something by a secret code name
um these are the kinds of things that
are really important
for communication that wouldn't make
sense in another context or place in
your life
cool one other thought and i wouldn't
quite characterize active inference as
an optimistic theory i i don't know if
it's optimistic or not but
what i really like as far as a starting
point for our uh
often discordant world is it starts
from a notion that everybody has a
unique perspective
and through shared resources they're
coming into alignment
and that's why we need intercultural
communication and
non-violent communication all these
types of ideas
whereas the other way to think about
communication
would be somebody has the true idea of
what this
ism is you know socialism is x and if
this person has the true one or this
book has the true one and then
those who diverge from it it's an error
term and so instead of thinking about an
absolutely correct
idea and then divergence that different
individuals have
whether a person is the one who holds
the absolute truth or whether no one has
the absolute truth and everybody's deep
in the error term
we can just think about meeting people
where they are
starting with the states that people
actually have
instead of um starting from some
hypothesized perfect
state and then trying to bring people
into alignment there
i think it's just a very helpful idea
and the secret language
and the intermodal to kind of put one
more finish on that
if somebody puts their um scare quotes
on the video
uh with their fingers which is a
non-verbal cue that suggests i'm using
this term
ironically or it could mean different
things but
importantly it might mean different
things in different cultures
so one might want to be very careful
when they're using
non-verbal or secret or culturally
specific cues
because if someone's not looking at your
video square the second that you make
those scare quotes
or you lag out for a second in the
context of online communication
your semantic content will not
update their model appropriately they
may think that you're saying something
that's quite the opposite of what you
intended to say
and so a lot of the times when people
are talking about how to improve
the communication throughput in online
meetings
and there's distraction that's kind of
the opposite of attention there's all
these issues that confront online
meetings and online teams
and people will say well use the body
language and use nonverbal cues
and yeah it's important to use those to
the extent you can but also
within this framework we can already
start to think about some cases where
maybe that
wouldn't help as much as we thought
especially when we're in the challenging
communication contexts like low
bandwidth
or different language speakers so these
are the communication
uh scenarios where we actually want to
have useful theory
we don't just want to describe the easy
low-hanging fruit of
two people who are twins and speak the
same language and read the same books we
want to talk about
the professor who's speaking with a
child about math and we want to get them
together on the same vocabulary and cut
those are the communication scenarios
that really
are meaningful to explore and the ones
that are so natural
to this skeleton but are not as easy to
model in other frameworks
um any other thoughts on this figure
yeah stefan
yeah i think it's like you just
mentioned in fact that they say
canonical
like this feels like it makes more sense
for deductive thinking
that you're trying to line up because
just having the brain there
obviously that kind of sort of it's it's
in this kind of
slightly disembodied slight way and
so okay i have a deducted idea and then
he was like okay what
is that and this this could make sense
now if we're gonna ground it more in
like my state
or my embodied
um feeling about something more
generally if i'm working in a more
iterative or inductive way or trying to
sort of
feel the situation abductively i don't
know if this
probably would be quite how i would
maybe one of the other diagrams is more
appropriate but this
may be that idea that an idea pops out
which would probably be a deontic
or you know deductive here's a new
equation and now it's like tick tick
tick tick tick you can imagine it being
a bit more schematic like this
nice agreed and um the five e's
uh that are sometimes brought up in
these papers inactive
embodied and cultured all these ways
that go beyond just
idea teleporting into another idea
that is uh it's not even like that's the
payload of communication
it's just we can come at it from the
other side by thinking okay what are the
bodies doing what is actually being
perceived in that embodied
setting and then yeah the ideas are
there
but um we could just as well have had
two
stick figures instead of two brains
because or we could have had a stick
figure over here for my behavior or
mouth or something
so let's go to figure four and five
which are
closer to empirical uh figures
and these are specifically in the
context of birdsong
so here's the upper part of
figure four and what is
happening here anyone wanna just
describe what they
see when they look at this
well on the x-axis of these diagrams
yeah sasha go ahead
um yeah so this is looking at um
birdsong improvisation and
um sound is a really nice way to do that
because
you can have a kind of a dimensional
reduction
and look at just the outgoing sounds
um instead of trying to analyze like
body posture and interaction which is
um quite challenging and um
when uh
birds sing together versus sing singing
alone
um we might imagine that um
we could take the two of them singing
alone and average it out
or something like that that could be um
one possible outcome
of when we put them together um
and then the other outcomes are that
they improvise and create something
completely different
that isn't just the average of the two
agents yes so from the caption
it says two birds endowed with prior
expectations
about the hidden states generating a
shared birdsong
narrative and i love that they called
the sheriff bird song
narrative um the way that it works it
says sing for two seconds and then
listen for a response so that's why
on the x-axis here where we have time in
seconds you have one
two in blue and then listen for response
one two listen for a response
the posterior expectations so that's
after the priors have been updated what
you get are posteriors
the posterior expectations for the first
bird are shown in red
and expectations for the second bird are
shown in blue both as a function of time
the left panel shows the chaotic and
uncoupled dynamics when the birds cannot
hear
each other while the right panel shows
the synchrony in the hidden states that
emerges when the birds exchange sensory
signals
so the the left image is kind of like
two people they're in two recording
studios
that are separated they can't hear each
other and they're both singing a song
it's a call and response song and under
the uh model or the ecosystem where
they're not sharing
a shared informational niche they're in
two isolated recording studios
there would be no expectation that the
turn taking would happen
um if if someone took off their
headphones and just was talking randomly
there'd be no expectation of turn taking
in fact to be quite impossible and so in
this
singing alone like singing alone with
two of the birds who are both seeing to
themself
um you see that there's basically uh
there's
there's strong discordances where the
one bird is like okay i'm gonna sing now
and the other one's like i'm gonna sing
now
and also just um i think this is more of
a schematic
but let's just think about this as like
a prefrontal cortex
this is where the higher order thought
is happening
and then this is like a motor cortex
this is where the speech is being
generated
between um the more basal regions of the
brain
and the more cognitive elements so on
this left side we have the bird
is singing it's it's um infer it's
deciding when to sing and also listening
for a response but it's not hearing any
response so it's uncoupled
you get uncoordinated dynamics however
when you
allow for the birds to sing together you
see
that they can synchronize so that they
can actually um
communicate and really importantly it's
not enough just to have the two
singers in the same recording studio or
have them listening to the same
sounds they actually have to have priors
that they want to strive towards
alignment because if someone says
yeah yeah yeah this is a turn-taking
song but i don't care about that
well then you're also going to get the
emergence of uncoordinated behavior
so you need the sensory coupling which
takes place through
the shared informational niche and the
adaptive prior
that the person or the bird that you're
communicating with
is an agent like you who also wants to
synchronize
because that's the cooperative part if
you're prior about your
your um conversions is that they don't
want to synchronize or that they're not
going to synchronize
well then you might not synchronize with
them you might not give them the opening
to synchronize
so when we start from this place of
communicative communicate or
cooperative communication that means
we're going to need that sense
coming to the person appropriately so
that they can turn take
but then at an internal generative model
level we also want to have
this deep prior about our communication
that we want to synchronize
and so a lot of the later work after
this paper
has gone into this more about how
individuals
who just want to believe or want to
reduce
uncertainty about a higher order entity
that they belong to
that is what can actually lead to group
formation
so this is a really interesting uh
concept
any thoughts on the top half of figure
four or can we jump to the bottom of
figure four
cool so here we are on the bottom of
and on these plots though the x-axis
is the second level expectations which
is like what you expect to be hearing
the first level i believe is referring
to what um like i'm
my first level expectations of my speech
are just what i'm generating
whereas the second level expectations is
what do they think
um what do i think that my conversant is
getting
and so on the x-axis of both of these
plots are the second level expectations
of the first bird
and the y-axis is the second level
expectations of the second bird
so here what's being communicated is a
number between
negative 20 and 60. but it's just a
number line so
yeah how how many uh or what's the price
of oil today negative 20 to 60.
we're trying to reduce our uncertainty
about this shared
niche and what we're seeing is um
we can just go to the right side first
the y equals x line this one to one line
would mean the second level expectations
of the first bird is negative 10
and the second bird got negative 10. so
this line
represents points on this line represent
where there's an alignment of
communication
because the expectations of the first
bird are aligned with the expectations
of the second bird
and we can see it really clearly on this
right side when they're synchronized
that whether the value being
communicated is negative
10 or whether it's 50 or 60 it's a
dynamical system so we're still getting
a trace that kind of flows above and
beyond the line
but we're spending most of our time on
alignment about what is being said
but if we go back to this isolated case
where there's no sensory coupling and
there's no
ability for even if there were a deep
prior that said i want to be aligned
with another bird
we're spending as much time off of this
y equals x line as we are spending near
it
because the birds are just uncoordinated
in their singing
and so this is just showing this is what
happens when you don't have alignment
and this is what happens when you have
synchronization and a manifold
is a lower dimensional line let's just
go with for now
that is a dimensional compression from a
higher dimension
so the points are in very higher
dimensional space but when you put them
down on the two-dimensional piece of
paper it makes a parabola
or in this case it's a higher
dimensional space
of two dimensions the expectations of
the two birds
yet it exists or it at least converges
towards
this one-dimensional manifold which is
just a line representing
from negative 20 to 60 what the actual
communicated state is
so this is just another a phase space
dynamical representation
of what alignment looks like in the
uncoordinated case
and then in the coordinated case where
you have sensory coupling and those deep
priors for alignment any thoughts on
this one
cool let's just go to five so that we
can finish the figures
and have any last thoughts okay anyone
want to take a first stab
on figure five what is being
communicated here
so in the caption of the figure it
writes
a shows changes in the posterior
expectations of an order parameter for
the first bird in blue and a second bird
in green
determining the chaotic structure of the
songs depicted in figure four
and so and it's as a function of the
number of exchanges so here
the x-axis isn't the time in seconds
with the two seconds of singing two
seconds of listening
now we're gonna those that two seconds
of singing and listening we're going to
condense that
into one exchange so now we're kind of
thinking in that iterated
um way so we're starting to get towards
iterated communication
here by condensing through time and
almost looking at kairos rather than
kronos
and then we have this uh value of a
of a order parameter and uh
yes so we have an order parameter and
what we see is that the order parameter
starts off high
again the green and the blue are the two
birds
and the green bird is starting
starts higher organization in both of
these traces the more dim one
the learning alone which is these two
dimmer traces and this the
line represents the the mean of these
simulations and the
the shaded area represents the um 90
bayesian confidence intervals just to
clarify that
so we can start up here this green bird
starts at
perfectly ordered and then the blue bird
0.5 so a little bit more disorder maybe
this is like a mentoring relationship
between a more encultured bird and a
younger bird who's on to genetically
learning how to communicate
and what we see is that when we have
the ability to learn together that the
order parameter
stays high and we can actually
increase the order of disordered agents
so for example if five of us had a
really good internet connection and one
person was lagging a lot
through cues we could help order the
person's communication even if they had
lack
however if we learn alone then
the order parameter even though it
starts very high for the green bird and
a medium for the bluebird in both cases
you get this exponential decay
so that after 30 bouts so 30 times 4
seconds
30 exchanges 30 choruses you have
zero correlation the order parameter is
zero
because they started out like partially
synchronized just by
happenstance like you told the two
singers in the two different recording
studios okay start singing
and initially they started just by
coincidence
synchronized but rapidly that decays and
it decays monotonically there's no
chance they're ever going to recoup
alignment because they're not
coordinated but again
if you are coordinated you can learn
together
and just like sasha was saying um when
you have improvisation and feedback
it's not just that the green parameter
stays at one and the blue one converges
toward it
it's actually that the two converge
together and they meet in the middle
which is just so
um reflective of communication and we're
getting this just from
birdsong this isn't at the semantic
level this isn't
at any other higher order level sasha
um this also makes me think of um like
you know the two
birds uh teaching each other the the
song or coming to a kind of more ordered
state
and mentoring relationships as well as
teams
um and while i think um people
kind of intuitively understand that
there's going to be um
some sort of meeting in the middle
linguistically to describe it um
but how to rise to that highest order
um and how to converge on something that
is
more ordered and not drop down to
something that is less ordered
um i think is an interesting question
for teens and maybe is a little more
straightforward in like a teaching
relationship where um one person is
quite
fixed and um both people know that
that's the fixed point to rise to um
from the student's perspective yep and
it's kind of like when we say
everybody can learn from everyone even
if one person's knowledge base totally
encompasses someone else's knowledge
base
at the very least we're learning how to
communicate we're learning how to learn
so
really we can honestly say everyone can
learn from every interaction with every
person
and now we have a framework to really go
into that
let's just close it out with five b and
c
so this is reminiscent of figure four
where again we have the expectations um
here are the second level and uh
expectations of the first bird and then
the expectations of that second bird
um and again we have this y equals x
manifold that would reflect
points on the line uh being in perfect
attunement where the first bird is
expecting to communicate 40
and the second bird's expectation is
also 40. so that's the uh
alignment of the internal models through
coupled communication and
a deep prior that you want to align and
what we see is that before learning
so now we're going to be talking about
this learning together trace
so before learning is here so before
learning
it's not as wacky as figure four was
where these are like all over the place
they're it's truly uncorrelated it's
like a cloud of points
here we're starting with a partial
ordering
the green order parameters one the blue
or the parameters point five
so this um oval is halfway between
perfect
and random um and there's some math that
we could go into
but not today but it starts off
partially organized and you need to kind
of start from a place of partial
organization for communication
and that's actually granted by evolution
and
the synchronization manifold before
learning gets tightened
to the synchronization after learning
where the parameters have been
improved so that now the birds are in
improved alignment yeah stefan
is your hand raised yeah sorry i was
just trying to
yeah yeah i just thought one thing was
interesting on the other
is the more experienced birds um
it's like there's still a slight dip in
their
coordination um as they learn as they
as you know in their kind of um
now maybe there's a trade-off but the
green one still goes down a bit and is
there maybe a sense that you need to
relax a little bit of the
rigidity of the pattern to enable
some compromise or some sort
i'm not exactly sure how they came up
with the the way that that that model
works but
that i just noticed that i thought
that's kind of interesting there that
that
there's a slip in that and maybe that's
just a degradation of
degradation over time it just happens
but there seems to be something about
that ability to relax the rigidity of
the model that you use totally agreed
and i'm
i'm thinking of a math setting where the
equations are
in the textbook and then one person
might be very familiar with them one
person has less familiarity so the green
person is teaching math with the blue
person and it's not teaching two that's
that absolutist idea they're
in a shared alignment they want to align
around a proper understanding of math
but the teacher person still has to be
ready to address
unexpected questions from a student
which may be extremely valid and
actually push the field forward by leaps
and bounds
by bringing that beginner's mind to the
equations um and if nothing else
the teacher might have to resort to some
informal metaphors
or say well this this parameter wants to
do this that's kind of
if you just think about it from the
textbooks perspective it reflects a
divergence
of that order parameter but it's being
used
towards this higher end which is the
shared alignment on the concepts
and so yeah very interesting and i i
wonder um
about that too um and maybe that's
reflected by initially the blue line
takes a
larger excursion away from order but
then it spends
it then converges a little bit more so
that's like when you have a first
conversation with somebody
and it's like um so where are we coming
from you're taking more of an excursion
towards this order to be more in the
explore phase
and then once you have a better sense
about where the person's coming from you
can enter into a more
exploit type phase um
i think that's um almost all for our
time and that's all the figures of the
paper
so on a closing page just if anyone
wanted to share um
uh closing thought or if they wanted to
share a question that they had an idea
or a future experiment so
anyone feel free to jump in or raise
your hand
uh i just want to say an idea what you
should never sing alone
is it a russian proverb
yes well singing alone could be nice i
mean solo performance can be
beautiful and uh it makes me think about
the
seeing the national anthem which is
often done with a solo performance
they might do a little bit of more vocal
flair or they might draw out a certain
thing
that would totally disrupt the um if
multiple people were trying to sing it
but when one person is doing it they can
have a lot more artistic license
but if you're in a choir context where
it has to be
synchronized you you can't just say well
today i'm going to sing it this way
it's not going to sound good um
and so there's there's there's maybe
times to sing alone but it's not singing
together to sing alone that's for sure
but are they singing alone i mean if
you're performing you're singing
performing for so you're engaging with
an audience of some sort
or a recording studio which still has
a implied audience
very true and um they're the the um
they have a paper this figure five
caption it's a duet for one
and so i think that the joke there is
it's one
dyad it's it's a conversation for one
this is a conversation for one
shared markov blanket it's a
conversation for one informational niche
it's one
team com it's one conversation that's
happening
it's not six conversations but there are
six perspectives happening and so that's
where i find active inference to be such
a powerful framework
because it helps us um really give full
value and cognition to six unique
perspectives
coming together to one shared niche and
so one fallacy would be well six shared
perspectives means there's no way we're
gonna synchronize that's a little bit
too defeatist and then the other
alternative would be well because
there's one
informational niche there's only one
conversation and if you don't get it
then you're not with a picture
and that's also not right but somewhere
in the middle we can have a shared niche
and our own perspectives
sash um
yeah just to close it out with the the
meta
uh connection um you know with the
words teaching each other how to sing
and coming to a higher understanding
um we're trying to come to a higher
understanding of
active inference and it was really great
to have the first author of the paper
here to kind of
align us and set the order so
that was really nice yep yep he provided
context to what we discussed and so it
was very
very nice to have jared come through any
other
thoughts
great well that concludes um team com
podcast number three
i really appreciate all of our
participants as
well as all of our listeners and we
really
are interested in staying engaged on
these topics and hearing people's
feedback we want to be
really uh inclusive and engaging with
how we're talking about these topics
from conceptual perspectives
uh and more so please be in touch with
us
and we will have this every two weeks so
we really
look forward to participating with many
of you soon
and i'm going to terminate this live
stream thanks again everybody
for participating and listening
thank you